thank you very much jubin let me figure
out how to share my uh
my screen here
um
so i have i've got copious notes i won't
be reading directly from the notes but
uh a lot of stuff that i want to make
sure we cover so so bear with me you see
uh yoda and anna wasp staring out into
the galaxy so uh i hope you'll kind of
see my theme i just want to kind of talk
about what stuff's uh what stuff's
happening in the in the
future for for those who don't know let
me just kind of quickly walk through the
history of how olaf started
um
recently in life i actually got
diagnosed as being bipolar um and if
you're familiar with or you know about
what bipolar is it's manic depression
it's the new word for manic depression
and uh mania is essentially where you
get fixated on a problem you you don't
take no for an answer you you
essentially do things that are
potentially risky potentially dangerous
and you you often don't listen to people
and it's interesting looking back on
life um about various things that have
happened um
buying crazy houses off of uh you know a
whim and all sorts of crazy stories that
uh that i can share but it's also
probably
owasp was created in a very mild and
early form of mania um which which is is
is kind of interesting
um for those who don't know i was
moderating a mailing list called
webappsec um way before the slack stuff
it i found the oauth slack recently
there's like 15 000 people on that slack
which is which is amazing
i think we had about a thousand people
on a mailing list it was a sister
mailing list for bug track if you're
familiar with what bug track is it was
the way that everyone discussed uh
security in general back in those days
and we had a bunch of people on that
mailing list and i was running software
security at charles schwab the big
financial services company um
here in the in the us in san francisco
and we got on the front page of the wall
street journal
we had a security problem it was a
cross-site scripting problem and the cio
came running down the hallway and said
who's the new guy running appsec and it
was me
and hey what's this problem and what are
we going to do about it
and what essentially ensued is that we
had had three people complained through
the call center
one was the person who ultimately
reported the problem um and then two
people were vendors trying to sell us uh
a magic technology solution for the
problem but the challenge i had as the
apsec guy is that when people were
questioned and say hey what you're
saying we should do and what you're
saying we shouldn't do these vendors are
saying this thing
what's the truth here where is the place
on the internet that we can go and look
at the independent information
and frankly i thought this is just crazy
this is absolutely you know nuts and
someone needs to go figure out how to
solve this problem
so
i went to a bunch of people that i
trusted on the web appsec mailing list
and said hey i'm going to go solve this
this problem a bunch of people said
you're absolutely crazy you're never
going to be able to be able to make a
make an impact you have to go and
document massive amounts of stuff you're
going to wind up with a whole lot of
people contradicting you
um but like i said it was uh so you um
i'm going to go ahead and do it and
what what often happens when you when
you have that condition as well is you
get itself into a mode where your brain
operates very very effectively and i
quite literally spent 48 hours over a
weekend without sleeping
writing a document and that document
ultimately became the first version of
the owasp guide it wasn't one of the
things that we launched with um and
frankly it was awful looking back at it
um as andrew vandestalk will tell you he
uh he had to rewrite pretty much it from
the ground from the ground up but
but that was basically kind of how it
how it happened we had a static html
website um
that if you wanted to go and update it
you have to uh use ftp to go
push a piece of content to it and uh
and away we went um
and honestly that is my last major
contribution to owasp i
started it i got the thing going but os
success is due to all the people that
have contributed
there have been massive amounts of
contributions over there over the time
and it's all of everyone's contributions
that have made the things successful
um
linus torvalds has a great quote he said
that one of the successes of linux is
because he's lazy and he likes taking
credit for everyone else's work um i
hope i'm neither of those things um so
uh
neither are those but you know the
success of any community in any major
project is a result of of everyone
coming together and loads of people
doing work
so on that note i want to make sure that
a bunch of people get get credit whose
names aren't often seen but were
absolutely instrumental in the early
days of of the project and
i honestly i kind of thought a lot about
this slide because what i didn't want to
do was to miss people out and there are
absolutely people that are missed out
here for sure
um and there's no there's no way around
that but
these are some names that you often
don't hear about that were absolutely
instrumental in the early days ingo
struck who's over in germany is a
developer extraordinaire and was working
on all sorts of interesting stuff in the
early days and he was a real developers
developer and was just absolutely
amazing
gabe lawrence who was still around
had actually tried to start an early
startup um building one of the web first
and i think it probably was the first
web application firewall um he and a
great crew were just too early to the
market um and as a result couldn't make
that company commercially successful
but instead decided to go open source
that code to to owasp and what was the
stinger project which was one of the
first first things
and as we've seen companies you know
signal sciences and and all these other
companies have been incredibly
successful with that technology they
were just simply too early um
david raphael was was building a a bunch
of tech mike de la barra has just always
been there um stan guzik ran the first
ever oauth conference in new jersey i
was logged on earlier and saw tim tom
brennan who's
is another name that's always been
around and but stan music put a lot of
effort into organizing these things um
and so you know a whole list of names
dennis cruz is uh is just a man who
makes me smile he is like the the
duracell bunny who is full of ideas and
just gets [ __ ] done and you know and so
and so it goes on but i wanted to to to
put those names up because they often
don't get credit from from the early
days
but it's thousands of people right the
whole project has been you know
incredibly um incredibly successful
um
so let me flick through um flick through
a bunch of notes so
this is this is the kind of section
that's almost like the best man's speech
right this is the wedding speech of like
reflecting on the last 20 years and uh
you can go because oh 2020 which is
which is quite phenomenal to to think
about it um if you think about what
happened 20 years ago i made a bunch of
notes here
the iphone didn't exist until 2007
quite mind-boggling aws launched in
2006.
years after oaus was started azure was
even later than that 2008
git which we all are totally familiar
with and you'll hear from a special
guest uh later about about git stuff
2005
when we first started owasp we were
using cbs if any if any developers are
that old that know about cvs you'll
you'll cringe completely but that was
what was used to to manage stuff in the
early days um firefox was invented
afterwards safari didn't even exist
chrome came along eight years later um
it's pretty amazing to think of really
you know the the people that kind of
jumped in in the early stage and just
how technology has changed over the
space of the last 20 years
if we sit and face down where we are
today
the application security space has
changed fundamentally as well back in
the early days of course we built
everything from from the ground up um
every piece of code people were building
crypto libraries and
were building everything themselves
these days we largely assemble
applications it's a combination of you
know things that are resources and
services that are online from aws you
wouldn't build your own crypto service
today use kms you
you wouldn't you know go and host your
own database you you spin up an rds
instance or something um so it's a
combination of infrastructure certainly
a combination of code that we run and
sometimes run in serverless manners
right and you know on the on the web
um and it's pulling data together from
various different places through apis
data lakes and all of those those good
things so things are fundamentally
changed um of the way we build stuff
we're today even seeing things like
infrastructure as code i was watching a
talk just now about about ci cd and you
know it's not coders code is still
everywhere but in many cases it's used
as glue it's pulling different things
together
so the last 20 years have seen massive
changes in in how we've done things um
we are still
faced with massive problems and massive
problems with open source um as steuben
said my my last company was acquired by
by vera code and that was doing open
source security around libraries
and that problem is as prevalent today
as it as it ever has been if we look at
what happened with solar winds and we
look at all of these supply chain
problems
there is no shortage of problems that
still exist and are far far from being
solved in that space alone
i have been doing a bunch of work
over the last i guess five years with us
intelligence and some of the
intelligence agencies and we've been
looking at
you know how prevalent their
vulnerabilities are in open source
libraries that are out there
and uh you'll hear later from uh from
steve christie who created the cbe
and when we looked at it i want to say
probably five or six years ago
there were about six thousand cds that
been had been reported and we
pretty
with pretty high degree of confidence
estimated that they're actually about a
quarter of them a quarter of a million
of them in the open source libraries
alone because all of the libraries are
getting copied
things like git allows you to get clone
and just essentially create digital
replicas not only do you make a digital
replica of the code you make a digital
replica of the vulnerability as well
so
over the space of the last 20 years
we're fundamentally seeing new types of
problems occur as this amazing
technology transformation
happens
um
what's also kind of worth reflecting on
is is a really fundamental change in in
oauth it was driven by jeff williams and
dave wickers who again you know names
were not on that previous list but have
massive contributions back into to owasp
is the wiki um when we started like i
said it was first a static website which
frankly incredibly hard for people to to
contribute to
um and the minute that was moved to a
wiki all of a sudden we democratized
content contribution um which made just
a massive change into the into the
project so
there's been some some amazing amazing
things that have that have happened
um that have gone over it i also want to
reflect i was watching sharif's
little video that he that he put
together on um on twitter the other day
that he he turned when he when he had a
bit of a cancer scare he turned to some
people that were in uh
in the in oas and and to talk to them
um and i have had
countless just you know heartwarming
things that have happened uh over the
years and funny stories
um and one of them happened recently dan
cuthbert um sent me a signal
and i was having a bad day um for for
whatever whatever reasons and i get this
message through from dan which uh
as you can read reflecting on 20 years
of obas mad to see what had happened and
uh i can tell you just heartwarming
moments like that make you realize you
know what community really means and
what people when they come together um
do
the the wall street summit is one of the
funny ones um
in the early days i was actually in in
lower manhattan and wall street with a
fairly big name sears chief security
officer
he's still a a chief security officer a
different different company now
and uh
quite literally sat across the desk from
him um when he uh very confidently told
me that he was really the guy that was
behind all of owasp and all of its
content
and uh i was absolutely mind-boggled
that
someone could could could say that um
and i tried to keep a straight face and
i um i swear i didn't keep a straight
face but uh you hear all these crazy
things um
the bottom one is a picture i was at in
singapore
where i had a had an office a great team
in my last company
and was talking i think it was hack in
the box which is uh which is a great
conference out there and afterwards a
guy came up to me and he said you don't
know who i am do you
and uh honestly i i didn't know who he
was um and he said my name's jim i was
like oh great nice to meet you jim um
and he said my name's jim giovardi and i
recognized the name but frankly couldn't
think and he said i created the first os
logo
and sure enough the light bulb went off
and again a random guy um on the
internet when we decided we were trying
to figure out how to create a brand said
i'll do the brands i can do graphics and
and jim there is responsible for that
and i think you know whatever it was 15
years later
you uh you realize these connections of
people
um
the top right is my is my lovely
daughter hannah who is is now 18 and she
is off at university in the uk she's
reading law
and uh you know uh she's she's a high
functioning young lady she's a year
ahead of our time and
and living life to the full um at a uk
university which uh which typically
means drinking an awful lot and enjoying
life and
about four or five weeks ago
my wife and i came out of our u.s
citizenship swearing-in ceremony and i
turn on my phone and there's a whatsapp
message from hannah
and uh
it was pretty clear she was at a party
we'll leave it at that it was it was a
fairly garbage garbage text
but the gist of the text was is that she
was at a house party and i think it was
like 1 or 2 am
and she said there is a bunch of drunk
computer science guys that are hobbling
in the room
saying how oh wasp is absolutely stupid
and they're much much smarter than they
are
and i thought to myself oh my gosh like
you know for a law student halfway
around the world to be at a drunk
student party and for people to be
talking about oh wasp is is just quite
phenomenal for uh for the impact that it
has had
um
so that's some interesting stories and
there are
many
many many more um of them
this is
a set of kind of comments that are
intended in the the best possible way um
they are not intended to be negative and
i just want to make sure that that's
that's um you know super clear um
they're intended to be kind of you know
um constructive criticism um and please
take it in in that way um because it is
interesting when you reflect back
and you know i
actively left os been about 2006 2007
and the reason i left is that when i
first started it my vision was is that
it would be a project for developers
um that we could provide guidance that
was really aimed at software developers
and that was kind of the authoritative
truth in software developers
i was very lucky when i was at microsoft
i
on my corridor by my office was a guy
called ward cunningham and ward was the
guy who created the wiki if you're
familiar with with that he was a huge
developer he was part of the agile
manifesto one of those people and ward
and i used to talk a lot frankly about
oh wasp and go for coffee and and and
what ward kind of shared and reflected
particularly about his patterns and
practices work is that
when a community forms then it tends to
swarm and it tends to be um the
collective uh direction
and you know he really kind of
encouraged me and said look you know you
can fight and you can swim upstream um
against this and you can really try and
make it become a developer community
but the reality is
what you probably need to do is to go go
go create another developer community
and try and attract a set of developers
versus a set of secure application
security people if you really want that
to happen people will tend to create
things to fulfill their own actions and
scratch their own itch
and that i think is true today and if
i'm critical
one of my things is that i think that
owasp hasn't fulfilled that potential
that i had that's not to say it hasn't
fulfilled massive impact as
as we all know
but i think it's fair to say that the
majority of people that come to oas are
already security people
and i think that that's a little bit of
a shame um a big bit of a shame um
i went earlier and i typed in the word
secure coding guideline
and
os was not on the front page of google
and when i clicked through
to the piece of content that was there
it had been created in 2010 and hadn't
been updated
and i think that's a real shame because
people look at oh wasp and there is
nothing out there on the internet today
we'll talk about that in a little bit um
but if i'm a developer and i type in
secure coding guidelines and i come to
something that hasn't been updated in
2010
i'm going to go elsewhere
and that's a huge a huge missed
opportunity
i think over the years as well
osprez has really failed to partner
unfortunately with with big tech
so when i was at microsoft i ran i think
with msdn which was the microsoft
developer network and tech net which is
a
a way we would see developer tools to to
the market we had a million subscribers
you know 50 million page views a month
and frankly had a very large budget my
my business unit would generate more
than a billion dollars of revenue and so
there was an opportunity for me to help
our wasp and
i offered to figure out how to brokerage
for microsoft to get involved on a
deeper level you you watch large
technology companies
really lean in to helping amazing
communities and is is one of those
amazing communities
but unfortunately kind of what what
happened was that um i was really just
asked for check um it wasn't a case of
hey let's go figure out we want to go
solve this problem together will you
fund it it was hey here's how you can
sponsor something
without anything tangible at the end
and i think the result of that has mean
is that oas hasn't been able to partner
with big tech in the same way that other
things have and we'll talk about the
linux foundation cloud native computing
foundation
um and i think that those are some of
the missed opportunities that have
happened over the last 20 years that i
hope don't happen over the next the next
20.
um
i'll skip the bureaucracy slide but i
just make the comment you know there is
a reputation for for bureaucracy and uh
and i'm not sure that's super helpful um
i went to attend a local chapter meeting
once and was told that my slides
couldn't be on my own slide format that
had to be done on someone's powerpoint
format and
and things and you know for a community
project it's extremely important that
you know it's grassroots it's not a a
load of bureaucracy in order to get
things done um
and i know that um the leadership have
been working incredibly hard on that and
uh and that's fantastic but i encourage
you to kind of continue to do the same
because
it's got to be easy it's got to be
friction free to do it
one of the very first things that i did
was establish vendor neutrality um
and frankly kind of before rappers had
beef on the internet i had beef with
someone around this and uh
you know um we won't name names but you
know what happened basically was that in
the early days someone said i want owasp
to mandate my product and the code was
indeed open source but it was gpl and
they were building a commercial company
on it and they wanted to to say that
this was the web app scanner
and frankly it was rubbish it was it was
not right um that is not vendor
neutrality
um and you know i i stuck my foot in it
like i said it caused you know
internet before whatever it is before
the term of internet beef and um
and and and it was really important and
i think the
vendor neutrality has been one of the
great things
i hope that that doesn't change um and i
hope that you know the relationship with
vendors doesn't change
but frankly i've attended some some
chapter meetings where
it's kind of like a timeshare pitch
before by a vendor
in return for for free pizza
i think osp is better than that there is
an opportunity to truly create vendor
neutrality
and build a commercial model which
allows that big tech and those people to
engage um
and i hope that that is uh that that is
is done um
so that's that um i don't wanna don't
wanna ponder on that i asked a bunch of
friends a bunch of people i know to
share what they think about oh wasp and
so i'm going to play you about five
minutes of of a video and i hope you
smile as much as i do watching these
hi i'm bruce schneier and i want to
congratulate oas on their 20th
anniversary
20 years ago application security was
kind of radical and a big deal
today it's common and
i don't want to underestimate the work
that owasp did to make that change it's
been great at being associated with the
organization
in the capacity i have been for the past
20 years
and i wish them uh another 20 years i
don't wish this was all 20 years of bad
thought for security but that's what
we're getting and owasp is there i'm
going to be there and thank you and
congratulations
i'm justin simani chief security officer
at unity i just wanted to say an
incredible and huge thanks to each and
every one of you making os the leader in
application security for the entire
industry it can be more appreciative of
each and every one of you solving the
most fundamental problem that i feel we
have in the entire industry congrats
happy anniversary and look forward to
more of the great work thank you
hi
this is chris weiss opal i was on the
first oauth technical advisory board 20
years ago
five years later i founded the
application security company varicode
i want to thank all the people who've
contributed to oauth projects over all
these intervening years
the sum total of all your work is an
amazing accomplishment that i never
would have imagined could have been done
20 years ago
everyone using the web and all
applications really is safer because of
you
hey everybody jen easterly from [ __ ]
here huge congratulations to owasp for
20 years as champions of the software
security cause
we greatly appreciate the contributions
that oasp and others make every day to
build awareness of just how important
cyber security is to our everyday lives
as i often say cyber is truly a team
sport and i'm super psyched that we are
on the same team sisa supports the work
of organizations like owasp as we
continue to bite down on vulnerabilities
to secure tomorrow and the next 20 years
keep on securing on
i'm john villega author of the first
book on appsec and i was part of owasp's
original technical board
i started out with high hopes for a wasp
dot dot dot
and honestly i've been continually
amazed by how huge an impact it's had
all across the industry it's been
amazing
so the day might not ever come where
appsec isn't needed anymore
but if it does
i'm confident it's going to be because
of owasp and it's amazing volunteers so
thank you all for your hard-working
dedication
hello this is jack daniel and i have
pulled my mobile office off to the side
of some highways somewhere because it
was important to say this
thank you and congratulations
owasp has been an amazing force for good
and for education in our field for the
past 20 years and it's thanks to all of
you from the founders to those of you
who have just put your toes in to take a
look at what owasp is all about thank
you and congratulations on 20 amazing
years
hi i'm steve christie coley from mitre
i'm a co-founder of both cve and cwe
owasp's success has been both a blessing
and a curse much like it has been for
cbe to the next generation out there i
love your energy i love your enthusiasm
and your innovation i can't wait to see
what you do over the next 20 years happy
anniversary everybody
my name is justin telly and i'm chief
security officer at sauce labs
over the past 20 years oasp has evolved
into the cornerstone of absence scanning
and analysis across the entire security
landscape
this is why we at sauce labs are
leveraging owasp's app to develop our
own security testing capabilities
many congratulations on 20 years of
incredible contributions to the security
community
hey there this is steve herrod i'm
former cto at vmware and an active
investor in cyber security at general
catalyst
uh congratulations to everyone involved
in owasp for 20 years 20 years of
contributions you've all raised the
awareness of the challenges and the
importance of application security and
really at a higher level you've helped
make this booming digital economy a
safer one
now obviously there's a huge amount of
work to do
a lot as you know but i'm confident that
your collective leadership and this
organization as a whole is really key to
that so once again congratulations and
here's to the next 20 years
this is michael howard from microsoft i
just want to take a moment to wish a
very happy 20th birthday to owasp it's
been a heck of a fantastic journey every
day i see the positive impact that owasp
has made to our customers to industry
and to compliance programs
never underestimate the impact that
owasp has had on this on secure software
engineering happy birthday guys
hi this is phil venables cso google
cloud on this 20th anniversary of our
wasp i'd like to say a big thank you and
congratulations to all of those who set
this up and have made it what it is
today it's really not an understatement
to say that web application security
would be in a significantly worse shape
today and so with cyber security overall
without this work really well done
congratulations on 20 years and uh best
of luck for the uh for the next 20.
hi i'm jim zemlin the executive director
of the linux foundation and i want to
congratulate olas on its 20th
anniversary
as you celebrate your 20th anniversary
and linux celebrates its 30th
anniversary this year it is amazing to
think how far we've all come
all of us here at the linux foundation
across all our projects admire and
respect the work that owasp has done
to help improve the collective security
baseline across the software industry
and across society
you know we all depend on software these
days for every aspect of our life and
the work that owasp does makes all of us
collectively safer
congratulations on the 20th anniversary
and here's to 20 more great years
this is tom pressenwarner co-founder of
github and prolific open source author
i'd like to thank everyone that has ever
contributed to owasp and all the amazing
work you've done to increase the overall
security footprint of the internet
because of you i finally feel like i can
take this thing off
i uh
i don't know what to say hopefully
you're smirking i can't see people um
as much as i am but uh you know i know
tom was smirking there but like that's
literally the founder of of github um
talking about the impact that oh ospas
had
um michael howard was the guy who
created the secure development life
cycle at microsoft when bill gates sent
out the famous mail
mike and dave leblanc wrote the writing
secure code book and they were behind
you know much of that stuff
jen easterly was nominated by president
biden and confirmed by the senate you
know to to to the um
the cyber uh security agency and
infrastructure agency
chris why sophomore you know who is one
of the nicest human beings in the world
um was you know was one of the loft guys
who testified in front of congress that
he could shut the internet down in 30
seconds
um absolute freaking legend um you know
you got john villega who wrote the first
book on application security jack
daniels who started b-sides um you know
i uh
it's hard to it's hard to kind of
sometimes take a step back and realize
the impact of that when i send bruce
schneier an email and immediately
responds back saying it would be an
honor to give a message to owasp you you
know the impact that it has had and uh i
just want to make sure that everyone
knows that because that is your work
that is the work that everyone has
contributed to has has that impact on
the project
um oh i'm restarting the slide i got to
figure out how to forward it versus do
that
okay so here's here's the final slide um
for this and um
this is frankly is my wish for a wasp
and this is you know is is things that i
would love to see happen over the space
of the next 20 years um whether it does
or not is is ultimately down to the
collective
but again what i hope is is that oh us
will have strong leadership because you
know back to the slide that i had of the
wasps pulling down the the statue
there's the old phrase that you know in
all the towns and all the cities there's
no statues celebrating committees and if
osp is to fulfill its potential it's not
going to do that through committees um
democracy is is a wonderful thing but
you have to have democracy where someone
sets out a vision for something and
everyone votes for that vision
if you don't have that things will
essentially stay in a status quo and
that's been the truth throughout the
whole of history
and there is a giant opportunity for a
wasp to really take itself to the next
step
and when i say next step of course like
look at what it's achieved so far it's
amazing i think uh andrew vanderstock
sent me some stats the other day i think
it was 130 150 000 people have attended
or rsvp2 events since
2019. um imagine imagine that i think
there have been three and a half or four
thousand events since since that time
it's a huge huge um input and huge huge
accomplishment
but i think that we are faced at a
precipice of where things are changing
you you heard at the beginning how
technology has has changed over the
space of the last 20 years
and uh and someone once said to me you
know what do you have any regrets about
oh wasp and one of them is calling it oh
wasp right wasp was an amazing catchy
name and it was probably partly you know
judah judah um
making it memorable but the the web
is is not uh well you know is not really
the focus of a lot of application
security today we are
sat here in essentially the second
generation of of cloud
the cloud vendors
um are being commoditized themselves by
the big data companies like snowflake
like databricks cloudera
and they are building on infrastructure
we see companies like netflix uh sorry
like netlify
you know basically create a full
end-to-end developer suite
on top again on top of cloud services
and so you are really in
the early stages of cloud 2.0 um and who
knows maybe it is not azure it is not
aws it is not google cloud
they'll come out of the winners out of
that snowflake is i think worth about 60
billion dollars right now and it's
essentially a
you know data data lake data warehouse
built on top of the cloud infrastructure
to make that data available to
application developers
so
i think it's really important that oauth
takes a look at that takes a look at
what's happened over the last 20 years
and ensures that it is 100 relevant for
what is about to happen in terms of that
industry
you will see things like machine
learning that become absolutely
prevalent and are all reliant on
software security we've seen attacks
cross-site scripting all of these sql
injection things
but imagine if we wind up with an era of
what are often referred to as salami
attacks when machine learning where
essentially machine learning our
machine learning algorithms all give
slightly different results each time and
they're slightly biased towards
something
we could see catastrophic
problems with with things like that and
application security has a massive space
to play whether it's through things like
formal methods whether it's you know big
data statistical analysis or you know
just looking at machine learning models
and all of those things themselves
they are all application security
problems that um i don't really see
people kind of looking at today um
cryptocurrency ransomware like it's all
driven by software and there's going to
be massive things that os needs to needs
to provide leadership around that
the next one is is that you know
communities are developing in very very
complex ways and its absolute scale
and there's an opportunity for oauths
today to basically partner or
essentially join with the linux
foundation and the cloud native
computing foundation
and i hope that it does um
that has been going for a long time and
if you are proud of the os
reach as as very well you should be
you can look up to that foundation as
having you know a step function up um 40
000 people go to conferences you know
hundreds of million millions of dollars
flow through through that foundation
and you know we can look at places like
apache we can look at places like the
cloud native computing foundation where
node joined the node foundation joined
we have kubernetes over there we have
you know hyperledger it's some of the
world's most important cloud software
and the linux foundation would really
like oauth to embrace that to lead the
application security part for all of
that software
and that's a huge opportunity for owasp
to take the next level and you know
essentially step up onto the world's um
the world's tech stage and and go help
drive the securing of that
and i don't think that that conflicts
with anything around the fundamental
beliefs that owasp has around vendor
neutrality about things being open to
all
but it is a change in the model it is in
some ways a top-down model versus a
bottoms-up model it's not relying on
individuals to contribute but it's
reliant on vendors and big tech to
contribute
but the impact that some of those
organizations have had has been
absolutely tremendous and the
opportunity and the reputation the great
work that oast has done allows you to
step into that plate
um and uh and frankly i've been trying
to help broker that uh that to happen um
or at least for it to be taken seriously
and uh and i think it's really important
that everyone understands that um you'll
also see the source lab sign down there
um i know you heard from justin dawley
who uh
csuf source labs former cso vmware and
servicenow and other great companies and
source labs are building on the oauth
zap project which is an amazing and
amazing project
but if we look at you know the
opportunity to essentially create an
end-to-end tool stack on what osp has
built
there really isn't a model there's no
commercial model again around for that
amazing software that gets built
to figure out how to partner with those
vendors and have those vendors
contribute back and everyone drives
drives further forward
i think if owasp had a chief chief
product officer um
which really is just a fancy way of
saying someone who owns product
management engineering and you know and
test and all those functions
that could pull together all of the
tools into a cohesive suite
os could quite literally have the best
end to end security suite for
application security in the world um
there is no doubt about that you have
dependency track this you know
jeremy long and steve springer an
amazing you know project we have you
know zap you know simon bennett's the
most amazing project and loads and loads
of others but they all work
independently right they haven't been
pulled together into into a suite of
tools and you know you saw you saw
thomas uh the founder of github like
the relationships
through people like me and other people
to get into the the the right people at
the industry to make these happen
could really get owasp tools in front of
developers and making massive amounts of
difference along with things like
getting into kubernetes and and all of
these great things so there's huge
opportunity there and i hope that owes
takes that that opportunity
um i think that um the last thing is is
that i hope owasp um you know becomes
the guardians of the galaxy and as well
as all of these projects that are going
on
get some momentum behind fixing things
um i know there are odd sporadic things
happening but
you know frankly i was in i was in
sydney in australia um meeting with uh
with the head of the apache foundation
just when the big apache struts thing
kicked him
and what struck us over a cup of coffee
and frankly one of one of the most
frustrating things for me was that
you've got a whole bunch of amazing
security people he had a whole bunch of
a bunch of legacy problems in in struts
and the two people weren't together
and i think that there's a huge
opportunity to mobilize these people you
with an amazing skill an amazing skill
set amazing knowledge that when these
problems occur in critical
infrastructure and all these these these
software projects that are powering the
world to secure them um not just keep
creating guidance for for other people
but jump in and go do the work um
because you can essentially become the
world's force of going and fixing those
those things and i think there's there's
there's an amazing opportunity for us to
go do that
so
that's that um i have a final you know
set of things that i would like to say
which is that
you know from starting osp um i
encourage everyone to go take a risk
right
things don't feel comfortable um when
you go do it but you've seen what
happens when i wasn't comfortable and
just you know who gives a crap what
anyone else thinks
go make a change um there is a massive
opportunity ahead of olaf's to go to go
make that change um and i hope that that
you guys take that risk um dream big you
can see what happens from some you know
silly idea and small thing and a mailing
list um don't take no for an answer just
drive through you've got to have
conviction in how you do things
um
you know there is this this phrase is
that um you know and and i know this has
been prolific at microsoft and other
places that if you don't cannibalize
yourself someone else is going to
cannibalize you
software security as you heard from
bruce schneier and everyone else is is
is one of the most critical things that
we're we're all faced with today and so
it's top of mind it's not a niche
anymore um and you know it is absolutely
critical for for governments for a big
tech company you know high-tech
companies and everyone else to go solve
um and i hope that our stays at the the
center of that but that will mean
reinventing itself
um and that will mean you know figuring
out how to adapt
um
the last thing is is that you know
i have met some amazing people you saw
that message from dan cuthbert sharif
andrew van der stock there are just
people that are just fantastic humans
and uh it doesn't mean to say you can't
have uh have conflict there's been loads
of conflict with owasp over the time um
from my sort of early beef to lots of
other things that have that have
happened um
but you know everyone uh that i've seen
treats everyone else is great humans
with with great respect and and i think
that is absolutely fantastic for for a
community to do that it genuinely feels
like a community and when you hear
sharif
you know turn to to someone that he met
through oas to talk about a potential
cancer situation which thankfully wasn't
wasn't the
the case um for sharif like you really
do understand how how good humanity and
and just being good to each other
matters and um and when you do that i
you know just want to encourage everyone
to kind of constantly think about that
you know life's too short not to do not
to do great things i know us frankly as
amazing and and as you've seen from uh
from all of the work that it's achieved
and the the credits from just those
those people in the industry
congratulations i don't think i can say
anything else um the achievement has
been amazing and
whether it's 10 years or 20 years i look
forward to coming back and
and talking again and watching the
continued progress
so thank you for